hey what is up guys i'm kphd here and
the samsung galaxy note 2 came out about
two months ago and ever since then it's
gotten a lot of attention there's been a
constant buzz about it it's always
brought up when you talk about the best
phones of 2012 the top high-end phones
the top big phones the best android
phones it's just always in the
discussion it is constantly being talked
about and i've carried a galaxy note 2
as my daily driver for these two months
and something i've noticed is i have
never gotten so many questions from
strangers about my phone than i have
with any other phone with this galaxy
note 2 be prepared if you want to buy a
galaxy note 2 if you want to be a galaxy
note 2 owner be prepared to answer
questions from strangers in public who
come up to you and already know that
it's called the samsung galaxy and want
to know more about your phone i think
it's weird that so many people already
know it just by sight part of it could
be the wealth of samsung as we already
see on it on tv and on youtube of course
part of it may be the fact that the
device is so big that it's hard to miss
when someone walks by with it it's a
little bit of a curious combination
between a tablet and a phone that makes
people want to know more about it it has
a stylus people are like what is it how
do you use it could i possibly get too
used to it it's just it's a weird
concept it's even become my most popular
review video ever damn that's a lot of
people basically this video is to help
you guys who are still on the fence
about buying a galaxy note 2 by
answering some of the most popular
questions i get about it a lot of people
want me to compare it to other devices
and to give a little bit more
information that i did in my review so
this video is for you guys first thing i
get asked about is of course the size so
yes it's a big phone there's no doubt
about that it has a 5.5 inch display as
we know and this kind of really pushes
it to the limits of what's usable as a
phone but it's nice because it's a
relatively thin bezel and you'll see
that it's thinner than the bezel of some
other phones like the galaxy s3 so it
doesn't really push the physical size of
the phone too big here it is in my hand
i'm about six foot two and i've shown
this before you guys have seen it i can
use the note 2 as a one-handed device
although it is quite difficult to sneak
a text maybe during class when your
phone's display is so big
but i've been told that i have really
large hands and i know that's true so
here it is in my mom's hand she's about
five foot five and was quoted saying
that this is simply too big to be a
phone so for her if you have small hands
you might want to make this a two-handed
device and consider that it's probably
always going to be a two-handed device
for you but if you have larger hands or
maybe just kind of semi-large hands if
you're anywhere over 510 this is
probably going to be okay as a
one-handed regular phone use which is
pretty neat so here it is next to some
other phones including the samsung
galaxy s3 which you've probably seen in
person at some point
and here it is next to the nexus 7 and
yes it is definitely still smaller than
a small tablet it also fits in the
pocket just fine i can vouch for
anything that's not skinny jeans and
also here's how it looks next to my head
while taking a phone call i actually
don't think it looks all that insane
some people thought it would but
especially from a normal distance away
you probably couldn't tell the
difference between that and a galaxy s3
another super common question i get is
about the display is it good enough i
mean it's big but is it good the droid
dna just became the first somewhat
popular phone with a 1080p display i can
almost guarantee that the galaxy note 3
in the second half of this year will
have a 1080p hd samsung display but i
honestly really like the note 2's
display it's not the brightest in the
world and the viewing angles are pretty
good they're not bad they're ammo led
displays but the point is it's big it's
a big clear beautiful display that
really makes this device people also
want to know about the stylus and to be
honest i just now use it occasionally
one for guester typing on the android
jelly bean keyboard that's been my
biggest use of the stylus super super
fast and very accurate and i also
started using s note just a little bit
but not for anything too intensive i
found it handy just to take random notes
during a phone call people also want to
know how is touchwiz holding up are you
gonna root it well i said before and
i'll say it again when given the choice
i prefer stock android no skin but if i
have to choose a skin i'll use touchwiz
pretty much every time it's still
running on top of android 4.1 jelly bean
here it's buttery smooth it takes
advantage of the screen size and the
stylus as well so yeah it's nice i'm
okay with it but when the black one
comes out i absolutely will root and put
cyanogenmod 10.1 on it and run a super
nexus with android 4.2 but this is the
titanium one so not yet also the little
things yes the camera is still very
high-end it takes great photos i share
them all the time on twitter and still
take some of the best 1080p videos of
any smartphone out there so it's
definitely worth it if you're in it for
the camera and yes the speaker is still
very loud and yes i did put a sticker
over the ugly verizon home button
branding i had to do that and yes the
battery life still lasts hours beyond my
expectations all the time it is still a
beast of a phone so in the end it's not
your average popular smartphone it's
popular for more reasons than just the
specs and what's on the inside the form
factor offers an experience that no
other smartphone out there currently
does and i can still recommend it for
that reason so in conclusion i don't
always get asked about my phone but when
i do
it's because it's a note stay geeky my
friends peace
you